i know it's going to be a process and
there's going to be moments of good
and moments of struggle but they really
have shown a ton of rhythm early on
there's levert accessing the mid-range
again especially those elbow areas and
then jared allen's doing a nice job
of making himself available on the
inside oh levert
beautiful breakdown slithering to the
rim
the net signed to that offer sheet which
was matched by miami a few seasons ago
levert stops oh what a look laverta
in the first quarter that has come down
quite a bit here in the second
that's just three of 15 from the floor
in the second quarter as leverk
to the hardwood puts that in it's not
realistic to ask guys to play
36 37 minutes a night when you're
playing eight games in 15 days
they're not robots lover great feed and
allen
slams it down a 9-0
magic run levert
will get it off and hit
at the buzzer karis levert ends the 9-0
run
harris with 14 he's the high scorer
right now for brooklyn
levert fading away and gets the roll
wow he has that down last season
[Music]
pretty fake and he gets inside for two
and just bodies through
close-up opportunity hachimura all
rejected
do not go in there on the throw
the cut rimron oh what a play
end to end for brooklyn look at this one
end comes over
and just the anticipation gets it on the
inside and then
look at him i and watch and realize he's
gonna have an opportunity picks up the
pace
beautiful job the other night against
phoenix he's going to be looking to put
up some money
[Music]
that's money karis a chance at a
three-point play
his teammates and just going to work
against robinson gets to his spot in the
middle of the floor we've seen this so
often
has been held to six points three of six
from the field levert
got a three karis lavert from
65 62 wizards levert
oh killer crossover and a chance for
three
karis levert slicing and dicing
and just his quickness to beat his own
man
and then brian tries to slide over to
help but it's that little shimmy the
crossover
and guys on the team have talked about
just him coming over
and you know what he was able to do just
in terms of bringing that to the table
with his confidence
karis levert johnson defended by smith
now it's levert he's been the go-to guy
levert
in the lane for two karis leverk stuck
on automatic
it's one of the ugliest dogs i have ever
seen in my life there's something tells
me you're gonna regret saying that
i'll have hurt nice move inside contact
banks at home it'll foul
well again levert against a very good
defender
takes the bump and finishes
20.
[Applause]
karis levert scoots inside he's
explosive off the dribble
they're lacking in size in the front
court camps are coming off a game where
he had five rebounds
five offensive rebounds against miami
nice setup from levert to allen for the
slam
the second
they go inside to brown nice catch block
from behind
good recovery from lavert the initial
pick and roll
so the smaller chiosa is on the very
athletic jalen brown and
you see the reaction right now brooklyn
just can't get any stops
celtics have had their way harris that
time gets a stop
outlet to levert levert able to throw it
down down the other end
you focus so much on deer and fox and
the numbers that bog zen is putting up
or what body heal does coming off the
bench
nice play by karis sliver getting the
deuce here comes
the other way trying to increase that
pace tlc
course throws it in oh and how pretty
are karis levert
ball no good from about 12 to 13 feet
out
tough shot stepping back contested and
multiple hands there
going to the iron
almost slips see if the nets can get a
look
nice crossover carriage gets it to go
at the buzzer and that should count
crossover gets by
one gets by two pretty finished
it's not that long ago and so just great
to see and also
they got together as keras levert gets
the floater to go it goes down through
the contact
back down almost headed it is taken away
karis levert
with bogdanovic on his back
his career being able to be active and
still maintain his body control
and he feels it he's waiting for
mcdonovich
this is inside he's missed all three of
his shots so far
aggressive all the time good job on the
pick-and-roll of being patient
gets in there and gets a three-pointer
the hard way
harris who's already in double figures
with 10.
[Applause]
the bird draws the foul drops the bucket
and send him to the line
[Music]
temple and he lays it in i just i gotta
be honest garrett temple was really such
a class act for the short time that he
is here with the clippers
temple was studying for his lsat during
the
stoppage trying to become a lawyer when
his playing days are done how about
paris levert
and the nets will take the lead into the
second quarter the question will be
about how much
and it's a lot count that basket and
lead again by 21. time now for the att
internet fast recap the recap is
this clippers team offensive rebounding
is one of them across the board
rebounding but especially on the
offensive left
[Applause]
love hurt the blow-by arms in the way
despite the fact that they give up an
offensive rebound
alan fowle from behind oh boy if it's
not a
modern-day three-pointer it's the
old-fashioned way for jared allen
and you look at the blazers team very
different as you mentioned that we saw
back
in november levert hits the mid-range
and that's something we've seen he was
going back on d we'll keep track of that
levert off a 24-point game the other
night
and he gives off to jared allen
defensive rating has not been too bad
for the brooklyn nets
they're number nine hit as he fires
counting for two and a foul
the foul high screen and roll with allen
and then from the back side it looked
like
mccullum got a piece of that body of
levert sending him through the
free-throw line right there
reggie when you think of the player you
see the quickness in getting the basket
the strength of the finish
of course the depth of his three-point
shot how about karis levert
he's in the ignition carris levert on
the go and you saw the pace
would anticipate that out of both these
teams however we're seeing it live in a
living color we
sure are levert with 10 points
already in this first quarter waits to
see what zach collins is going to do
and in there cj and here he has been
great
very much a part of why the blazers are
five and two defeat give and go
and harris got it with a nice feed by
karis laverse
fourth the defensive end beautiful block
on collins here's a drive by
trent knocked away down court in the
corner that's a
three card now here comes karis levert
play with the bruised left thigh a
little bit sore
allen the screen up high it goes to
allen
and they let him get it they're so
worried about
that high screening role in him knocking
down those 30-footers
lillard with 16. inside they go
and pulling the trigger another
offensive rebound allen
volleyballed it back a new shot clock to
work with here comes levert
in doubled up and down oh what a play
paris levert second shot opportunity
here for the nets
and it's levert
pushes flips up the layup won't go
good job not fouling as he throws his
body
[Applause]
i asked team leader cal lowry if he
thinks ciaco is ready for the moment
he said i think he's ready we're going
to find out even if he ain't
we're going to make him ready best in
the nba doing that if officials
do see that and think ah it's kai lowry
probably taking a charge
levert gets it ahead and kuruz banks it
in
slide in let's take a look at that
offensive run by rhodion's code snatches
it keeps it high
was the key he's exactly right and you
know what the translation of taking a
charge is
i want to win carrots
fumbled it a bit almost was deflected
out of his hands nice play hanging on to
it
off the mark from three-point range
lever shake and bake
good find harris open look he sticks it
a three for joe
harris citizen thinking he's gonna walk
home to show his toughness
instead of going to an in an ambulance
my goodness
how to prepare his body for the long
runs and the understanding that this
thing is hard and
you have to be in the right position he
said from then into now
i'm a different person i've always had a
chip on my shoulder since i was a little
kid third quarter underway as brooklyn
brings it up again brooklyn one of the
surprises
here in the nba bubble nice start the
first possession
and they cut it 20. the scrappy nets
for the strong third quarter to get
themselves back in the game
levert fakes drives takes some contact
count it and one
he's awfully good he's facing
two guys every time he touches the
basketball and
still the ability to get to his spot get
the contact elevate
and get the hoop from three in that
first game three or ten so
different start for those two let's see
if the outcome is any different
great pass drive and kick coming off 15
assists so he's going to find a role
whether it's with brooklyn
or another team but he's displaying the
versatility and then he's a big guard to
go over the smaller guard on that drive
offensive rebounds beautifully done
allen
finger roll at the rim van fleet coming
up short
now the downhill guard keras leverton a
big guard at that
on the euro and going to the line
looking for the three-point play
two they can score the basketball you
know and a lot of it is
system oriented but obviously back to
brooklyn the surprising nets
up by a dozen as they are eight of
eleven from the field four or five from
beyond the arc overall
the jared allen on the hammer the opener
of the series coming up well
short there levert on the run before the
consent defensively got what he wanted
yeah and that's an example where the
transition offense
it's only a seven point ball game
neither team shooting all that well
right now after a real hot beginning
and well by the way justin anderson
thought it was for him
rebecca thank you it started out with a
pretty decent look
for luau cabaret now there was a
challenge from ciaco
marc gasol got tangled up and tyler
johnson got the worst of it
now off the turnover garrett temple
founded by anna nobi he'll take it
strong
can't score karis levert lines it up
bottom six nothing lead levert from
downtown
down help there by garrett temple and
take a look at karis levert
see if the nets can continue this sweet
offensive start levert off the handoff
from allen
here he comes slithering into the paid
off balance and he's headed to the
free-throw line
brooklyn nets up six well this is what
he does
well all the time he's a guy who can't
create
shots he is a pure scorer number of
three-point attempts they're gonna try
to contest them hard
and they've done a great job of that
being the best
three-point percentage defense in the
league
well they're shooting 61 from the floor
i don't know what jack vaughn's options
are to be quite honest as we watch
first the business at hand here can they
finish strongly
down 3-0 to the defending champs laverge
steps into a top three contested and
he's got everything going
so when he's shooting it well there's
really no answer to him
some incredible stat lines for the
raptor zabaka looking for more
outside on inoby driving kick it's
intercepted levert
this is a foot race wins it against
gazolin goes to the left hand
the double team and anovi intercepted
levert anticipates
and now the acceleration by levert as he
lays it in he got the angle
on gasol just joined us kyle lowry left
ankle sprain left the game late in the
first quarter will not return
raptors have told us nothing more than
that as levert with a chance at three
by some good defenders right here norman
powell a good defender
he gets by him
38 of 65 59 karis levert
wow